>> Susan Reyburn: Okay,
I'm Susan Reyburn,
Curator of Baseball Americana.
An exhibition currently running
here in the Jefferson Building,
and continuing through
July of 2019.
If you haven't had
a chance to check it
out yet, I hope you will soon.
Since we're talking about
Babe Ruth here today.
I'll point out that the
exhibition has several items
related to The Big Fella.
His playing shoes, an
incentive agreement he had
with the Yankees, a
1933 baseball card.
And clips of him on
the, on the field.
As well as his appearance
as himself
in the 1928 silent film classic,
Speedy, starring Harold Lloyd.
Today we continue
with the second talk
in our three-part series on
New Baseball Publications.
On Tuesday at noon, we'll
hear from David Rapp.
Author of Tinker to Evers
to Chance: The Chicago Cubs
and the Dawn of Modern America.
But this afternoon, the
library is very excited
to have with us Jane Leavy.
Author of the highly-anticipated
new book, The Big Fella:
Babe Ruth and the
World He Created.
It is available for sale
at the back of the room.
And after the talk, Jane will
be on hand to sign copies.
Then with your brand-new
book, head upstairs
and check out the exhibition.
If you are a fan of baseball
and of beautifully-written
and deeply-researched
biographies,
you are probably well
aware of our speaker today.
Jane is the author
of highly-acclaimed,
best-selling works on two other
towering baseball figures.
Sammy Koufax and Mickey Mantle.
And if you have not read A
Lefty's Legacy or The Last Boy,
be sure to add them
to your reading list.
She has also written
a novel, Squeeze Play,
about a newspaper beat reporter
for the Washington Senators.
Which drew on her
own experiences
as a Washington Post
sportswriter.
At the Post from 1977 to 1988,
she covered baseball, tennis,
the Olympics, as
well as pop culture.
She is a graduate of the
Columbia University School
of Journalism and
her work has appeared
in numerous magazines
and anthologies.
As for The Big Fella, Jane
spent eight years researching
and writing this book.
A challenge not only
because Ruth lived large.
And left behind an extensive
trail-blazing past full
of rabbit holes to explore.
But if I may abruptly
jump to another metaphor.
He represented a perfect storm.
The coming together
of the best player
with the biggest
personality on the best team
on the largest stage in the
country's most popular sport.
During an explosion of
media possibilities.
No one else has ever occupied
that unique intersection
in American life.
And who better than this
award-winning biographer
and lifelong fan
to tell his story?
Offering new insights just
when you thought
there was nothing more
that could be said
about Babe Ruth.
So ladies and gentlemen,
Jane Leavy.
[ Applause ]
>> Jane Leavy: I'm going
to steal what she just said
because it's better than I did.
Wow! And I'm also
taking off my shoes.
That's the next thing
that has to happen here.
[Laughter] Oh!
Much better.
So hi, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
I, she's taken a little
bit out of my speech.
Hey, where's the clicker for
moving the pictures, guys?
Anybody know?
[ Inaudible ]
I was going to say
some of that stuff.
What you don't know
about me is this.
I now hold a Major
League record.
Which is for spending most
consecutive nights alone
with Babe Ruth.
[Laughter] More certainly
than either of his wives
because he could leave them.
And he couldn't get
away from me.
And it took eight years of
intimate conversation between us
for me to figure out how
in God's name to tell a,
not just a new story about him,
but to tell it in a new way.
When I started out, I
had this image that's
up on the screen in mind.
From the very, very beginning.
It was taken by a
very famous fashion
and celebrity photographer
in 1922.
At the Polo Grounds.
And what enticed me about
it, aside from the fact
that by the way, the publisher
got permission to flip it.
He actually was sitting
the other way.
But it, they flipped it because
the big, the big box store said
if you have his face on the
right, our sticker's going
to go right in the
middle of his forehead.
So they flipped the picture.
Which I'm stunned the Estate
of Nickolas Muray agreed to.
Nickolas Muray was a Hungarian
photographer and fencer
who would ultimately
die in a fencing match.
But he was known for taking
pictures of people like Mar,
Marlene Dietrich and F. Scott
Fitzgerald, and Claude Monet.
And Frida Kahlo with whom
he began a ten-year affair
after taking her picture.
So this was not the ordinary
guy Babe Ruth was used
to being shot by.
This was a guy who
wasn't just looking
for the perfect mechanics of
his swing or his uplifted chin
as he headed down
the first base line.
This was a guy who
was looking for him.
And I think it took me a
while to realize it, but the,
the reason that the picture
means so much to me is
that it posed an
essential question.
What is he trying to hide?
Look at how he's
holding himself in?
Now that hunch was
characteristic of him.
And it became more so as he got
fatter and the belly went down.
But even by then, and he's
relatively young there.
Look at how much he's
protecting himself and look
at the size of his hand.
Which frankly I had
to argue very forcibly
with the publisher
to show that much of.
They wanted to obscure
the whole thing.
And I said, "You
cannot have a picture
of The Big Fella
with The Big Fella.
And not show the size
of that, that hand."
So that posed the question
from the very beginning.
What's he trying to hide?
I spent a year, a whole
year, reading everything
that had been written.
about him between hardcovers.
And softcovers, and a lot
of the newspaper stuff too.
Because I knew that the first
question was going to be,
wherever I went, "Why in
God's name another biography
of Babe Ruth?"
And I was going to have to
find something new to say.
And if there wasn't anything new
to say, I wasn't going to do it.
So I read everything
there was about him.
And what I discovered
was that there's no boy.
There's no little George, the
name his parents gave him.
In any of those biographies.
He's a cipher.
He doesn't exist.
Now, I've been saying this line,
now it's really a
pleasure to say it here.
If you tried to write a
biography of Winston Churchill
or God forbid, Donald Trump,
and left out his childhood,
you'd be laughed out
of this institution.
You could not write what
would pass for biography
without somebody's childhood.
And the formative
years that created,
in this case, The Big Fella.
But in sports biography, which
is sort of a weird sub-genre,
what passed for biography
was really stories
about somebody's career.
Was the, was the life of a
career, not and an athlete.
Not really the life of a person.
So I knew that if I was going to
figure out who The Big Fella was
and how he became that person.
I was going to have to
find that little boy.
So, hoping this works.
There he is.
And what it says on
there, in his handwriting
because he autographed it
to somebody named Ethel, no,
Gertie, Herbie and Gertie.
It says, "What a nice
little boy at age three.
But now, wow."
Typical of him.
Also the lack of grammar
was typical of him.
He flouted expectation and
authority and governance
in every single way,
including grammatically.
But if you look at that
little boy, look at his eyes.
They're no different
than the ones
of The Big Fella you
just were looking at.
And they're sad eyes.
Now part of this is
just physiognomy.
It's the set of his face.
But it's not all physiognomy.
And what's significant
about this picture
to me is that's a picture of a,
a kid comes from a
fairly well-to-do family.
People who were really
dead-broke
as his family has
always been described.
Don't get posed like this at
age three in a frilly collar.
So this, too, was a clue
to me that something
about the childhood,
the skimpy biography
of his childhood was way off.
So there he is, and I'm walking
up and down in Baltimore.
The street that he
took when he was sent
to St. Mary's Industrial
School in Baltimore
when he was just three
years older than this.
That's part of the biography
that everybody knows.
That he was sent off to what
is often called an orphanage.
And that's why people
thought he was an orphan.
He wasn't.
Or sometimes they said
he was an incorrigible.
That was a legal term
of [inaudible] meaning
that the court sent him.
So he was a bad kid,
a wanton kid.
A reckless, ungovernable
kid, hanging out on the,
in the foggy ar-- , areas
around the Baltimore harbor.
That wasn't him either.
And I figured if I'm going
to find out what it felt
like to be six, seven
years old and dispatched
to this reform school when
you do have two parents.
I'm going to want to
know, I'm going to be able
to reproduce exactly
what he saw.
As life as he knew
it disappeared.
So I took pictures
from the B&O Railroad
which has a great collection.
Because their, their whole
installation was near that area.
I took a 1902 insurance, Sanborn
map, Sanborn Insurance map.
I took the cards, the index
cards that had been collected
by the Enoch Pratt Library in
Baltimore that describe what was
at every intersection
in Baltimore in 1902.
And I walked up and down
West Lombard Street where,
according to Westbrook Pegler,
his first ghost-written
biographer, autobiographer.
Where he allegedly
took, with his daddy,
the number nine streetcar when
his parents, hard-working,
broke parents reluctantly,
tearfully, sent him off to live
with his Xaverian
Brothers, who ran St. Mary's.
So I'm taking pictures, and
I've got this whole thing.
And I go out Wilkins Avenue.
And I'm getting out, and
I'm walking in places
that my kids don't want me
to walk because it's not
such a good area anymore.
And I write the first
chapter of the book.
I know this is the
beginning, right?
It's a formative
experience, being sent off.
The trip from the home,
from home to the home is
the thing that created him.
And then one day,
[inaudible] in August 2017,
long after that chapter
was written.
Up on my screen pops,
for no apparent reason,
a story about a Baltimore street
cop named Harry C. Birmingham.
Somebody can look him up for me.
I can't remember if he
was Patrolman 468 or 469,
but he worked out of the
western district in Baltimore.
And his area was the
bars along Camden Street
where George Herman Ruth,
Senior, ran a bar at the corner
of West Camden and
Packo, South Packo.
Just a block away from the
train station that was the site
of commerce and tumult and
noise and industry in Baltimore.
And I'm reading this story.
This nice-looking guy
in his big, tall hat.
And his Brilliantine moustache.
And he looks great.
And he says, You know
it was my pleasure
to take George Herman
Ruth, Junior,
out to St. Mary's
for his father.
I didn't think a young boy
should be raised above a bar.
Harry C was a teetotaler.
He thought this was not a great
place for Babe Ruth to be.
And so he volunteered because
George Herman Ruth, Senior,
was an old friend of his.
To take the boy away and
take him to St. Mary's.
Well there goes the tearful
journey with daddy, right?
And what's more, he says, "He
was a mischievous kid, sure.
But no more so than
any other boy.
And he certainly never gave us,"
meaning the police,
"any trouble."
There goes the bad kid.
So all the pillars on which the
biography, the accepted wisdom
about Babe Ruth was
built, disappeared.
Just crumbled.
So that meant I had
to start over.
And I had to start doing
a whole lot more research.
Because now I knew that
something had gone on in
that house and in that
childhood that I had
to get to the bottom of.
Well one of the things
that's happened that people
in libraries know about.
Is that the availability in
just really the last ten years,
I guess, of digitized
archives, newspaper archives
but also state archives.
With birth records,
death records,
divorce records, arrest records.
And probate wills, everything.
Means that what I started
out thinking was going
to be a terrible
disadvantage to me
which is there was
nobody alive to talk to.
Nobody presently alive, as
Casey Stengel might have put it.
[Laughter] Was not the
disadvantage that I had feared.
Because what I had access
to that Robert Kramer,
Marshall Smeltzer, Robert Smith,
Cal Wagenheim, Tom Meeney,
and last but not
least, Lee Steinberg.
Not Lee Steinberg,
Lee what's-his-name,
Lee Montville, sorry.
Couldn't get access
to was the following.
Babe Ruth's parents
were divorced.
Babe Ruth's father,
George Sr., found his wife,
and this is a direct quote from
the deposition of the divorce.
He found his wife with his
bartender, also named George,
on the, quote, dinging
room floor.
And he accused his
wife, and she admitted
to [door slam] oop, sorry.
Trading sexual favors for booze.
Kate Ruth apparently
had an alcohol problem.
George Ruth filed for
divorce immediately,
two days, month after.
It was advertised in
the Baltimore Sun.
"I will no longer, I am
no longer responsible
for Katie Ruth's debts."
Period. When the divorce was
finalized on May 6, 1906,
it was published in
the Baltimore Sun,
the Baltimore American.
Now what tells you
is George Ruth,
Sr. was a pretty prominent guy.
He wasn't this, you know,
slug of a poor bartender.
He was important enough
to have his divorce be
on a page of the newspaper.
So suddenly, it's like you
know, all you remember,
when we had those
kaleidoscopes, in childhood?
We're all old here, so you
know, those cardboard things?
[Laughter] With the pieces
of glass that would just sort
of tumble and fall into place?
That's what that
moment was like.
It was oh my god.
He suddenly makes sense.
Also in those records
were the birth
and death records
of his siblings.
Now his sister Mamie,
who was the only one
who survived to adulthood.
Always said that Kate Ruth
gave birth to eight kids.
I could not find
the set of twin,
twin boys she said were born.
But I could find
these six other kids.
Of those six kids, four died.
Two of starvation.
And little George
Ruth, that kid,
watched his brothers
and sisters die.
One by one by one.
And despite watching them
die, he was still sent away.
So what are you going to think?
You're seven years old, not
eight, as his mother told him.
Because she got his,
his birthdate wrong.
You're going to think, what
did I do to deserve this?
You got two children left,
and you still don't want me?
So off he goes to St. Mary's.
Where he is raised in
dormitories with hundreds
of boys, 130 boys on one
floor of a dormitory.
That was made for 90.
They slept in wrought iron cots.
Head to toe, with just enough
room between the rows which kind
of looked like pinstripes,
frankly.
For a bentwood chair,
and to get at,
down on your hands
and knees and pray.
There's not room for a
single personal item.
There's no deviation
in any of the beds.
They look exactly the same.
These kids ate together,
slept together,
went through puberty together,
and they played baseball
together.
Because baseball was not just
something to do at St. Mary's.
It was an organizing
principle and a way
of channeling a whole
lot of hormones.
And so what Babe Ruth knew,
and what he was comfortable
with was being with
crowds of boys and men.
This is at, in Syracuse in 1925.
Look at them draped around
his neck and his shoulders.
Like one of his wives' fur boas.
They're all, there's
5000 boys that tried
to get into a single frame.
There's also one
little girl there.
I don't know if you can
see her over in the corner
on somebody's shoulders.
She just looks just like I did.
I had same horrible haircut.
[Laughter] And but they can't
get close enough to him.
And he doesn't care.
Not only does not care that
they're draped all over him.
Try that with Bryce Harper
today or Aaron Judge or.
There's not a hint of
claustrophobia in that smile.
"He chafed at every constraint,"
his daughter Julia tells me.
Including having his feet tucked
under, in under the covers.
But not at this.
This is where he lived.
This is where he was most
comfortable in his skin.
And this is why he
was the perfect person
to be America's first
modern celebrity.
The focus of that kind
of mass adulation.
Being public is what he knew.
Being alone was unnatural to
him and uncomfortable to him.
This photograph is
taken on July,
hold on a second, July 26, 1926.
And it's taken at the same
airfield on Long Island
where Lucky Lindy would take
off for Paris ten months later.
And it's a PR shot that
was organized by his agent.
And among the many ways
that Babe Ruth was a
revolutionary is this.
He hired the first sports agent.
A guy name Christy Walsh.
A failed newspaperman, failed
cartoonist, failed ad man.
Failed PR guy who
in desperation went
to Babe Ruth's hotel
room, snuck in the window.
Slapped him on the ass, and
said, "I want to represent you."
Babe was in bed with a blonde
at the time, by the way.
[Laughter] Babe, and Christy
Walsh would do anything,
anything.
And Babe Ruth would
agree to do it.
To promote him, to
maximize his income.
You can't believe what a
radical notion that is.
That a, that a ballplayer
should be treated economically
as an entertainer.
Not just for what
he did on the field.
But for what he brought
to the field.
What he brought to
the New York Yankees.
So I happen to have here
with me an expert on that.
His name is Michael Halpert.
He's a Professor of
Economics at University
of Wisconsin, Lacrosse.
Michael, only his mother
calls him Michael, I'm sorry.
Mike has been my go-to guy for,
we think it's three
years, maybe four.
He when you look at the book
and you look at all the numbers
that are in there,
that makes sense
of this vast marketing operation
that Christy Walsh created.
Mike's responsible
for all of them.
And one of the things
Mike explained to me was
that when Harry Frazee,
the really stupid owner
of the Baltimore, of the Red
Sox, decided to sell him off
in 1919 for the 1919
World Series
because he was a
pain in the neck.
And because he wanted money
that he frankly deserved
for having helped win
all those World Series
for putting tushies in seats.
Jake Rupert, the president,
the owner of the Yankees,
I know a lot of you
hate the Yankees.
I'm sorry.
He was really smart.
He paid $100,000 for him
in four installments.
But Frazee was so broke, tell
me if I've got this right, Mike.
He was so broke that he
also borrowed $300,000
at seven percent interest.
But Ruth, the purchase
of Ruth was $100 Grand
at six percent interest.
Don't even keep doing that.
Which means that
after six years.
Tell me, Mike, I'm
doing this right?
Okay. After six years,
Harry Frazee had paid more
than $100,000 in interest.
Which means Harry Frazee paid
the Yankees to take Babe Ruth.
[ Laughter ]
Mike, could you stand?
Could you stand up, Mike?
This guy's amazing.
[ Applause ]
So he becomes this eco--
economic juggernaut.
Oops. And he becomes
this economic juggernaut
at this absolutely
unprecedented moment
in American history
and technology.
This is the back page
of the Daily News,
America's first tabloid.
The back page went,
became, became a thing
for the first time
in November 1919.
A month and a half before
Jake Rupert bought Babe Ruth.
And a month and a half
before Prohibition came in.
So Jake Rupert, no
dummy, as we see.
Knew that he was going to have
to make some money some other
way other than selling beer.
What's he, what's he
going to make money at?
And he had lost money in
this ball club for the free,
for the three previous years.
He's going to make
money off the Yankees.
And how's he going to make
money off the Yankees?
He's going to bring in Babe Ruth
and have him hit a
whole lot of home runs.
And the new tabloid press and
the radio which was just coming
into existence in terms
of popular entertainment.
First ballgame broadcast was
broadcast in August 1921.
The, from Pittsburgh.
[Inaudible audience
comment] Thank you, right.
Exactly right.
That's all in the book.
I got it. [Laughter] And
so this is, this is 1920,
so this is before radio.
And before radio and before
telepics and telegraphs
and all the mechanisms for
disseminating news that,
that we now think
are old-fashioned.
Right? Every sports
story was local.
Your, your, your
fame was as wide
as the circulation
of a newspaper.
In short, as far as the
newsboy could throw.
And now suddenly it's
going everywhere.
In 1925, the Chicago
Tribune and the,
and the Daily News invented
a system called telepics
which meant that they could
overnight a photograph.
It was expensive.
But they could overnight
a photograph from New York
to Chicago or New York to
Los Angeles which they did.
When Joseph Patterson, publisher
of the Daily News decided
to out Babe Ruth's
mistress, Claire Hodgson.
They also used telepics when
he hit his sixtieth home run
in 1927.
And by 1927, so much had
changed that two networks,
radio networks, two
national net, radio networks.
NBC which went live on
New Year's Day 1927,
and CBS both broadcast the
World Series coast to coast.
That is just six years
after this picture was
taken at the Polo Grounds.
And that was taken because
fans on the East Side
of Manhattan had no other
way of getting updates
from the ballpark about
what was going on during a,
the pennant-deciding series
against the Cleveland Indians.
So this guy come with his
pigeon, who's flying back
and forth from the Polo
Grounds to the East Side
of Manhattan with updates.
So 1921, September 1921, a month
after the first game
was broadcast,
1927 national coast-to-coast
broadcast
of the, of the World Series.
It is impossible for us, except
maybe if we remember pre-
and post-computer, to understand
how fast the world was changing.
And how big that was
going to make Babe Ruth.
I love the pigeon.
I really had to, I tried to
find the guy's relatives.
I couldn't find it.
Anyway, okay.
Hold on.
Now I know why people
lick their fingers.
Which I always thought
was gross.
So with the mass media came
the advent of marketing and PR.
This was all being designed
and invented and propagated
by three guys in New York.
Ivy Lee, who represented
the Pennsylvania Railroad.
Edward Bernays, who sold
soap and Lucky Strikes,
and God knows what else.
And Bruce Barton, who
sold Calvin Coolidge.
[Laughter] So now
you've got mass media.
And you've got a famous
guy, and you're going to put
that together with what?
Disposable income that has
suddenly become available
in the post-World War I era.
And this is a picture
of Babe Ruth standing,
I think it's outside the Ansonia
where he stashed his blondes.
And that's where Cristy Walsh
found him in bed with a blonde.
And he's reading a,
a, an endorsement
for the instruction book
from Walsh's first client.
A, a, a racing guy, car
guy named Ray McNamara.
So what you have here in
this fabulous picture.
What a great car, you know?
Is synergy, branding,
product placement.
It's all starting
there, and Christy Walsh,
who was really the original
Jerry Maguire, and a visionary.
Is putting Babe Ruth together
with his other client,
one that's going to help this.
One's going to help that.
You know, synergy.
Synergy actually in those days
was a medical term but it,
it's been hijacked since.
And with all these broadcasts,
and with the newspapers
came mass adulation.
One of his granddaughters
said to me, "Everyone wanted
to claim a piece of The Babe."
I told a radio station
this morning
in Alabama about this picture.
I'm not sure they
were so thrilled
with my disquisition on this.
This was taken in a
bandbox in Alabama
as the Yankees made
their way north.
They always barnstormed north.
And one of the ways that
Babe Ruth made money was
that he was paid to appear
in every exhibition game.
It's been written that actually
he would be fined if he didn't.
But that's wrong.
They did it the other way.
It was the carrot,
not the stick.
And Mike, do you
remember how much he got?
>> Depends on the year.
>> Okay, this is '25, I think.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. Not, not chump
change then, you know?
So these folks are, you
know, consigned to the part
of the ballpark as there was
in every ballpark in America,
that was open to
African Americans.
But look at them
reaching for him.
And what this picture speaks
to among other things.
And is you know the
reason it's so lovely
and significant historically is
you might know, not know this,
but it goes back
to the beginning
and not knowing about
his childhood.
People thought he was passing.
His mother must have
passed over.
Hmm? Look at those lips.
Look at that nose.
There was absolutely
no scientific evidence.
It is not true.
One of his, his grand,
great niece contributed DNA.
I had it tested.
Not true. But it was based
on playground stereotyping
that caused him to have a
nickname that I'm not going
to repeat because it's bad,
starting with the N-word.
And the black community,
throughout America,
believed he was passing
and believe--
secretly believed
he was a brother.
And wanted to believe that
because that meant they could be
or were being represented
in Major League baseball years
before the color barrier was,
was broken.
Okay, next one.
This is Babe Ruth with
his first wife, Helen.
And their adopted
daughter, Dorothy.
Taken at his farm in
Sudbury, Massachusetts.
It is quite simply a PR shot.
Taken by Christy Walsh
who sent him there
because he'd gotten himself
in trouble and they needed
to clean up his reputation.
And so off to the, to the
country he went to chop wood.
Which he paid other
teenagers to do.
And he actually had a
car designed, a Packard,
with a 55-gallon tank so that
he could drive back and forth
to New York without
having to get gas.
And he would spend the
weekends in New York.
And then he would
come back to Sudbury
and pretend to be Farmer Ruth.
Now I want to say
about this family,
because I think it's
actually, it's quite tragic.
And my editor says I
can't tell you everything.
So you have to read the
book, what happened.
But that little boy
who had no family,
who was dispatched
by his family.
His first instinct when he
got out of St. Mary's was not
to eat everything, smoke
everything, screw everything.
Forgive me.
But that's how ballplayers talk.
It was to marry the first
woman who was nice to him.
A waitress at a coffee shop.
Helen Woodford.
And in that, I, I find
that incredibly touching
because what's he trying to do?
He's trying to give himself
the family he never had.
And he is conforming,
not defying,
but conforming to norms.
That it didn't work out, that he
didn't know how to be a husband
or a father is hardly shocking.
It's true of many
Major Leaguers.
But that was his first instinct.
Not to be the reckless,
rambunctious,
out-of-control guy
you've all read about.
That said, he treated
his first wife terribly.
And he didn't do very well
by his daughter, Dorothy,
who's the little one between
him and his second wife, Claire.
Who he'd began a
relationship with in the month
after Yankee Stadium opened.
And he would create
a new life with.
They would adopt each
other's children.
Julia, who's on his right,
is that right, his right?
Is still alive.
She's 102 years old.
And when I first met
her, she's the one
who gave me the first clue that
there was something missing
in the, in the arc
of his, of his life.
She was the one who
said, "Oh, by the way.
Did you know that Kate and
George were separated?"
And I went, "Oh, no."
But she also told me this.
That explains some of
those appetites later.
She said the one thing he
ever told her about his life
at St. Mary's was that
he never felt full.
Now that's not just a
statement about the fact
that the Brothers
had all of six cents
to feed each child each day.
It's also a statement of
deprivation and the absence
of the love, guidance,
familial support
that you would have
wished he would have had.
This is Babe Ruth,
probably at his happiest.
He's out fishing at the end
of a Vaudeville tour in 1926.
Where he was happiest
was with the guys.
Doing guy things.
And there was everywhere
he went, there were guys
who were happy to buy him
booze, to get him broads,
to take him fishing,
to take him hunting.
Whatever he wanted,
it was there for him.
And this is taken
off Coronado Beach.
The two guys on the left
are fishing reporters
who both wrote stories about it.
The other guy is,
was a man-about-town.
Very handsome devil named
Carl Clint who, wasn't a fixer
so much as he was a guy
who would make sure Babe Ruth
would get whatever he wanted.
He wanted a fishing charter?
He was there.
He wanted a bathtub full of gin?
And they stayed friends
for quite some time.
At the end of that barnstorming
tour, this picture was taken
and send back to New
York to show Jake Rupert
and Miller Huggins, the
manager of the Yankees.
That yes, he was
taking care of himself.
[Laughter] He was resting up.
Now if you look really closely,
I think he's playing possum,
as my mother would have said
because the one thing
about Babe Ruth.
That made him the
"Ultimate American,"
which is how The New York
Herald Tribune described him
when he died.
Was that he never sat still.
He was restless and
he had the energy
of the country as
it was expanding.
Before the crash.
And you know he, he,
anybody Yiddish know you a
little Yiddish?
He had shpilkes.
He just could not sit still.
And he was the epitome
of that decade.
Hyperkinetic, ruthless, and
ineffably upwardly mobile.
Before this season, on, on New
Year's Day right around when
that umbrella picture was taken,
he was called by a newspaper
that said, "Have you got
a New Year's resolution
for the Yankees?"
And he says, "Yeah, I
promised 60 home runs to Jake."
What a thing to say!
He hadn't hit more
than how many?
Fifty-- ? Fifty-nine
since, in 1921.
People had thought
he was washed up.
He crashed and burned in '25.
And while he had a
good season in '26,
he also ended the World Series
by getting thrown out at second,
trying to steal second base
with two down in the ninth.
So nobody really expected
much of him in 1927.
And hot, damn!
This was a man who lived to
make promises and to keep them.
So he runs around the
bases on September 20,
1927, crowing, bellowing!
"Sixty, count 'em, sixty!
Let's see some other
son of a bitch do that!"
[Laughter] And right after
that, he leads the Yankees
to a four-game sweep of
the Pittsburgh Pirates.
He hits the only two
home runs in the series.
And then Christy Walsh,
the, the, the, the emissary
of SWAT takes them
out on the road.
On a barnstorming tour.
Scheduled to go to 21 cities and
replete with lots of PR shots.
This one says, "Appreciation
to Matt Gallagher
for doing the best
ballyhoo on our tour, 1927."
And I love it just because
I love the language.
But Walsh, who was as
straight a dude as he looks
like in his, in his suit there.
I think he was born
in a three-piece suit.
Was only four years
older than Babe Ruth,
but he became his governor.
He became a father figure.
He by this point, he had tricked
Babe Ruth into saving the money
that he otherwise
would have spent.
All the money that he earned
on the barnstorming tours
and the Vaudeville tours and the
products and the appearances.
Christy Walsh tricked
him into saving.
On his 33rd birthday, which
would have been February 1927.
He said, "You know, Babe, it
would be a really good trick
if we got all these
bankers together.
And you announce
that you're going
to fine yourself a
thousand dollars per year.
For all your bad deeds, and say
you've reformed and you're going
to put it in a, in
a trust fund."
Right? So Babe says,
"Yeah, that's cool.
You know, I'll do it."
Babe would do anything.
And he signs the check.
And when, as soon as the
cameramen go away, he says,
"Okay, I'll take my money back."
And Christy says, "It's
an irrevocable trust."
And that irrevocable
trust which Mike analyzed
to a penny to explain how.
And this is all in, in the book.
How it is that Babe
Ruth did not go broke.
In 1927, this year, the
year this picture's taken.
Babe Ruth is on the first
year of a three-year,
$70,000 contract with
the New York Yankees.
He also makes $73,000
in outside income.
If you put that together,
according to my friend Mike.
In 2016 dollars, that's
$36 million dollars.
That's how much he was making.
That's how rich he was compared
to the average American.
And Christy Walsh, by
virtue of tricking him,
got him to save what
otherwise clearly would have
been dissipated.
Because he was dead
broke in 1925.
Okay, let's see.
Now, when I say he would do
anything, I'm not kidding.
He was the ultimate gamer.
This was a guy who
needed to please
and got joy out of doing so.
So this is a photograph
taken at the AMCO plant,
the American Milling
Company plant
on the barnstorming
tour of 1927 in Omaha.
And this is where we
get really modern.
Because they suddenly said, "Oh,
this chicken is the champion
chicken egg-producing layer
of 1927.
She's laid 166 eggs straight.
Let's change her name from
Lady Norfolk to Babe Ruth,
the Babe Ruth of layers!
And let's bring Babe
Ruth to the henhouse!
And let's have Babe Ruth
cradle the other Babe.
And let's put little stories
in every newspaper in America."
This was on the wire service.
"Two Babes."
That's the picture
that went out.
And it wasn't just that
he was willing to do it.
He's obviously having
a really good time.
And I actually, believe
it or not,
was able to find
footage of this moment.
Which has never been
screened before.
So here you go.
It takes a little bit but,
and it tells you a little
about the Nebraska
egg industry first.
Which is what they were
trying to shill for.
But here it goes.
And by the way, that was
not very good compared
to other egg-laying states.
Two champions.
[ Laughter ]
And that's where the
still comes from, right?
And then Lou gets the 171st egg.
[ Laughter ]
Want to see it again?
It's really cool!
[Laughter] I love-- oh.
Oh, well, sorry.
We went to this is taken
just a tad later on the tour.
With a little boy named
Jack Whitey Stewart.
And Jack Whitey Stewart
was the bat boy
for the San Francisco Seals
of the Pacific Coast League,
which was basically considered
the third Major League.
And he got that exalted job
because his father was
a San Francisco dog cop.
He had the, he walked
bloodhounds
around San Francisco
looking for bodies.
And when he wasn't doing
that, he volunteered
to do security for the Seals.
And so young Jack here gets
to be Babe Ruth's bat boy.
I found Jack's daughter.
And son who contributed
this picture.
So this has never
been seen either.
And the reason that I wanted
to include it is
look at those hands!
Look at them.
I mean, the one that he's got
on his hip looks like a backhoe.
[ Laughter ]
He wasn't just huge
as a marketing guy.
He wasn't just huge in
terms of what he made
or the number of
home runs he hit.
Or how far he hit them.
He was literally
bigger than the game.
He was 6'2" and when
he was in trim,
which he wasn't exactly here.
When he was with
the Red Sox in 1916,
he was probably about
195 pounds.
Here he weighed himself
that say in San Francisco
and he weighed, he weighed 235.
And he said, "That's
a lot of weight."
But he was so much
bigger than everyone else.
Bigger than the pictures-- you
can find footage and I, I have.
Where he's the, the stuff
that they're throwing
him is such slop.
That's for you, for people
who don't know baseball,
that's junk, slow, whatever.
That he would have to shuffle
his feet in, in the batter's box
to try to time how slow it is.
Today that's known as
the Babe Ruth drill.
For batting coaches
who use it for guys
who they say have
a dead lower-half.
When they're trying to teach
them to catch up with the ball.
So he took pictures like this
with boys across the country.
None of them show his enormity
better than this one does.
And Jack, who for
reasons that I don't,
I still don't understand this.
Children don't understand.
Came away from that
experience a bit embittered
and didn't think he
was such a nice guy.
And say that Lou Gehrig
didn't want to pose with him.
Because Gehrig didn't
like his morals.
How an eight-year-old
was supposed
to know that, I don't know.
But by the time Jack died,
he'd come to a different
understanding
of his relationship.
Oh, there it goes again.
With Babe Ruth.
And when he died,
he was a member
of what's called the
San Francisco Baseball
Alumni Association?
Yes. Old-timer's
Alumni Association.
And at his wake, Jack was buried
with the Jersey he wore the
day he was Babe Ruth's bat boy.
So this is Babe Ruth
as king of the world.
And that's what I really
wanted to do in this book.
I wanted to give people
a feeling of what it was
to be Babe Ruth, at
the top of the world.
And what it was like to be
with Babe Ruth when he was
at the top of the world.
It never got any better
than this for him.
He just kept doing
the same thing.
More of it.
Yankees didn't actually win
that many more World
Series with Ruth and Gehrig.
Except of course the
famous one in 1932.
Where he hit the
[inaudible] at Wrigley Field.
No, I don't know.
I don't know.
[Laughter] So he played
until the Yankees decided
he was too old, fat,
and slow to be on their roster.
And he went to the Boston
Braves, back to Boston.
And the only team
that would have him
for a very brief time in 1835.
And then he quit.
Three weeks after he quit, he
made his first public appearance
at a West Chester, New
York, country club,
playing at a charity
softball game.
He has grease paint
whiskers and,
and this ridiculous
uniform that's supposed
to be from the Swiss navy?
I mean, really?
[ Laughter ]
And all, all the fancy people
from West Chester watched
him make a fool of himself.
And if you ask what his life was
like for the next 13
years, it was like this.
That's all there was for him.
Baseball turned its back on him.
The institution that
he had come to regard
as a family had no use for him.
And the saddest part about it,
and you can certainly
see sadness in that face.
Is that it was in
many ways a re--
, a reincarnation
of the abandonment
that he experienced
as a young boy.
He had been abandoned
once again,
and he couldn't possibly
understand it.
Any more than he could have
as a seven-year-old boy.
So the last 13 years of his life
were a series of ridiculous,
sometimes money-paying gigs.
A brief half a season in a
Dodger uniform where he got
into a fight with Leo Durocher.
And was blamed for it even
though he wasn't responsible.
And then he got sick.
This is his last birthday.
He's 53 years old.
He's got nasopharyngeal
cancer, not throat cancer,
not esophageal cancer.
Nasopharyngeal cancer.
Which my friend [inaudible]
here,
the doctor, helped
me understand.
And translate all the stuff
I wouldn't have understood.
And how did he spend his
fifty-third birthday?
With two little boys
he didn't know.
He would be dead
six months later.
But not before he went to Yankee
Stadium for a belated farewell.
This is not Babe Ruth Day.
Babe Ruth Day was the year
before and the Yankees declined
at that point, or forgot,
if you want to be generous.
To retire number three.
So on the 25th Anniversary of
the 1927 team, they gather,
they gathered all the old guys
together and brought them back.
And they said, "You know, Babe,
why don't you manage
the old-timers?"
How cruel is that?
This man who just wanted to
be, have a place in baseball.
I mean, how much did
he want to manage?
I don't know.
I think he just wanted
to be wanted.
So what do they offer him?
Manage the old-timers
in this game.
But it was raw, it was cold.
And he was too sick
to stay for the game.
So he never did manage
at Yankee Stadium.
This is the day that Nat Fein,
New York Herald Tribune
photographer took the picture
that won the first Pulitzer
Prize for sports photography.
And it's the opposite
of this one.
It's the one that's
taken from the rear
where you see the number three.
Coming up out of the dugout.
Eddie Robinson, later a Yankee,
he's now the oldest
living Major Leaguer,
by the way, and a lovely man.
Saw how hard it was for
him to climb up the stairs.
You know those, those
steps were pretty steep.
And as a young man, you'd gallop
up and down them in your spikes.
As a man dying of cancer, very
weak, and in a lot of pain.
Eddie said, "I think he
might need some help."
So he gave him Bob Feller's bat.
Bob Feller was the
starting pitcher
for the Cleveland
Indians that day.
And Babe Ruth used it kind
of the way you would
use a, like this.
He had his two hands like this.
So that he could actually push
down on the step like that.
It wasn't enough
to just one hand.
And he got himself up.
Took a few paltry swings
for the photographers.
And he said his farewell.
He was dead two months later.
And a hundred thousand
people passed by his casket
in the rotunda of
Yankee Stadium.
Where finally the
Yankees found a way
to greet him and bring him back.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Questions?
I went, I went long.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Well Jonathan's insight into
that came from Eleanor Gehrig.
So you know in, in 1927 on
this tour, they're buddies.
Babe Ruth's showing Lou
Gehrig as a young guy.
He's probably a virgin.
He's never been west
of the Mississippi.
Goes to Ogden Canyon,
and he's surprised
that there's no cowboys
and Indians, you know?
He was a naive kid
from Upper Manhattan
with an overbearing mother.
Babe Ruth was the
motherless boy.
So in a way they were a perfect
pair and they were friends.
And if you read the book,
please read the book.
[Laughter] Their relationship
then is amply documented.
The, the old trope is that what
got in the way between them was
that the second wife, Claire,
dressed the first child
from his first marriage,
not as nicely
as she dressed Julia,
her own daughter.
Dorothy's own children
said to me, "You know what?
She was so provocative and so
angry that if they said dress
up for the newspaper guys,
she'd climb in a coal bin."
She was a tomboy,
like me, actually.
What really put the kibosh
is when they went to Japan
after Babe Ruth played his last
season for the Yankees in 1934.
And they go off to
barnstorm through Japan.
And Helen, Eleanor, excuse
me, and, and Claire run
into each other on deck.
And they say, "You know, this,
this feud is really stupid.
You know, why don't you
come back to our stateroom?
Babe's got some caviar
and champagne."
Well, Eleanor says, "That
sounds pretty good."
And so she goes and she
spends the afternoon with Babe
and Claire, drinking
champagne and eating caviar.
While Lou Gehrig, the
earnest bridegroom,
is searching the horizon
for his dead wife.
[Laughter] And when he finally
finds out where she has been,
and she was quite
tipsy, you know.
He wouldn't talk to
her, to her for a week.
And he didn't talk to
Babe Ruth for five years.
So that's that story.
Okay, somebody else?
Yes, sir.
>> Yes, which actor do you
think best portrayed Babe Ruth?
>> Jane Leavy: Babe Ruth.
[ Laughter ]
And he played Babe Dugan in
one of his movies, you know.
He could play himself
better than anybody.
They're all awful.
[Laughter] Yeah, back there?
>> Parenthetical question.
You mentioned that his
father was more of a man
of means than people thought.
Why did two children
die of starvation?
Was there some sort of
neglect or abuse of those kids?
Jane Leavy: Surmise is, has to
come-- I mean, the, the death,
cause of death listed on the
birth certificates is marasmus.
Which is an old word
for malnutrition.
You know, there, there's
evidence, and I spoke to experts
about what life was
like in Baltimore.
That because it was one of
the last unsewered cities
in the world in the
United States,
the rates of infant
mortality were much higher
than they were elsewhere
in the United States.
There was no refrigeration,
there was no pasteurized milk.
But even given that, the
percentage of children
that they lost was way
higher than what was going
on in the city in general.
I don't venture a guess.
I mean, was it because
she was drinking?
Maybe. Was it because you know
there was a lot of disease?
You know, and, and
they were susceptible?
I mean, there had been plenty
of epi, epidemics in Baltimore
in the, in the 1880s and 1890s.
Death certificates
don't tell you that.
They just give the
cause of guess.
[Inaudible]
[ Inaudible Question ]
Michael. [Inaudible
audience comment] Mike,
you have to answer that for me.
>> Michael Halpert: Yeah,
he wrote a great book.
And [inaudible] because in 1919,
you have no idea what
Babe Ruth is going to do.
So when James says
that this turns
out to be the greatest
steal in history.
That is [inaudible] true.
But in 1919, it wasn't
that obvious.
That it was, it was going
to be a big deal because,
because [inaudible] said
predicting is really tough.
Especially if it's
the future, right?
[Laughter]
>> Jane Leavy: Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Well the French really
hated him.
And he didn't like
them back much either.
He went back through France.
Certainly he is given
fairly a lot of credit
for the development
of Japanese baseball.
But at the same time,
the guy, one of the guys
who was responsible, newspaper
guys who was responsible
for bringing him was stabbed
to death by a nationalist.
Shortly after Babe
Ruth left Japan.
So the, the, the seeds of what
would take over the world,
you know, six years later
were already present.
In fact, you know, the Japanese,
apparently the Samurais said,
well, you know, they had this
to-hell-with-Babe-Ruth cheer.
And the Kamikaze pilots would
go to their deaths, you know.
"To hell with Babe Ruth."
So the New Yorkers sent a,
a, a guy to his apartment
on Riverside Drive to ask Babe
how he felt about that in 1944.
And Babe Ruth said,
with his aplomb,
"Sounds like the
itty-bitty ones."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah?
>> Did Babe Ruth have gambling
problems [inaudible] known today
to be suspended?
If he had one, how
serious was it?
>> Jane Leavy: Did you
all hear the question?
How serious was his gambling.
His spending and
gambling were a big deal.
He was broke between fines that
were imposed by the Yankees.
And you know, all, all through
the first half of the '20s.
And his pro-- really, truly
profligate/generous lifestyle.
He was dead broke.
And when he and his
first wife Helen agreed
to separate in August 4, 1925.
He had to come up with
a hundred grand for her.
He was in arrears on all of the
four payments that he owed her.
And he had taxes to pay.
And he had to go to
Christy Walsh for a loan.
And Christy Walsh, being the
smart guy that he is, said,
"Yeah, I'll, I'll lend you
the four grand that you need.
But from here on out, you're not
to buy any real estate
without my approval.
You're not to take any-- .
You're not spending a dime."
And he took over as
his power of attorney
in complete financial control.
And he had the leverage
at that point to do it.
And it was the best thing that
ever happened to Babe Ruth.
I mean, he was dead broke.
And yet he, he bet
on the ponies a lot.
I've never heard or read
that he had a problem betting
on baseball, like
certain guy, Pete Rose?
[Laughter] Okay, take one more?
Okay. Yes, sir.
>> Tell us mortals what it's
like to pitch at Yankee Stadium.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
>> Jane Leavy: Well, I
will leave you with this.
It was my dream come true.
I mean, I practiced as a child,
walking in from the bullpen
at Yankee Stadium with
my Yankee jacket slung
over my shoulder, just so.
Like Ryne Duren.
Ryne Duren was an early relief
pitcher for the Yankees.
Threw very hard and
very fast and very wild.
Because he couldn't see.
And he always made a point
of throwing the first pitch
all the way to the backstop
to scare the bejesus out of
whoever might step to the plate.
So I, I was prepared, you know.
I, I practiced all summer.
And by the end of August,
I actually could throw
sixty feet, six inches.
And then I got some
advice from Sandy Koufax.
He said, "How far
can you throw?"
This was actually in June.
I said, "Oh, forty,
forty-five feet."
He said, "Stand thirty."
[Laughter] By the end
of, just before I got,
I went there, my arm went dead.
I got a dead arm.
[Laughter] So I call
up Koufax, and I say,
"Sandy, I got a dead arm."
He says, "Hmm, dead arm.
There's a very good
shiraz named "Dead Arm."
Get a good year.
It's a really good wine."
[Laughter] I don't
remember what it was like.
I was in a trance.
[Laughter] If you
go to the videotape,
it looks like I bounced it.
But as my daughter said,
"Mom, you threw a curve."
[ Laughter and Applause ]